the TSA has become an unlikely star on
Instagram with a huge number of
followers it's funny and educational
post post rather an effort to share what
can and cannot be brought onto the plane
the account is more than three million
likes Kris Van Cleave met the man taking
the post to new heists you could say
he's at Reagan National Airport that's
outside Washington DC Chris good morning
good morning you know the TSA is not an
agency that's used to getting a whole
lot of praise in fact most people try to
spend as absolutely little time right
there as humanly possible but where they
are spending time is online at their
Instagram page and if you're not
following well you're missing out
the TSA can be pretty bossy shoes off
laptops out arms up
liquids small but the TSA can also be
pretty funny
at least online where it's Instagram
aims to show the agency's human side by
posting a mind-boggling litany of items
people try to bring on planes what is
that it's a shrunken voodoo head made
from a goat that's the thing I love
about this job is you just never know
what you're gonna see from
post-apocalyptic fully loaded gas masks
to batarangs plenty of guns and those
propane tanks you just needed to have
with you on a flight the TSA has seen it
all this dead body was screened in
Atlanta don't worry it's actually a
movie prop and yes it was clear to fly
talked about deadheading Bob burns or
blogger Bob as he's known runs the TSA
is Instagram his endearing combination
of weird items and corny captions have
earned him two webby nominations 750,000
followers and the number four spot on
Rolling Stones list of must follows
that's a head of Beyonce I was expected
Kanye to come knocking at my door to
tell me I didn't deserve number four he
still might never know Bob a former
musician in Gulf War vet who joined the
TSA after 9/11 runs the account from his
home office outside Cincinnati Ohio he
says he's always on the hunt for the
bizarre the educational or when all else
fails a super cute dog like Rufus he's
the TSA s most liked post the purpose of
the Instagram account is to kind of show
but all the things we're finding
nationwide and educate people on what
you can and can't bring so if you're in
a pinch about what to do with a giant
Maine lobster Bob's got you covered
but if cringe-worthy puns aren't your
thing that TSA is also on Twitter where
from this command center outside
Washington they offer up to a thousand
real-time answers a day to more
straightforward questions like can I
carry on this face mask you can't carry
it on but you can check it
Jennifer plows a oversees social media
for TSA I mean you don't think about the
TSA as a customer service organization
our goal was only to be able to help
passengers and I think in the end that
this program has really helped to soften
the public perception of TSA a softer
image Bob's helped build one like at a
time what is the secret to being
successful on Instagram and being funny
on Instagram asking for a friend
will tell your friend the secret is to
share items that can create conversation
blogger Bob is a father of two and he
says his inspiration is corny dad humor
does admit he feels some pressure now to
be funny and educational with all of
these followers but the one thing they
don't joke about are the guns that they
post the TSA is on a pace to set a
record for guns recover two checkpoints
again this year
Chris thank you Bart's not never know
where interesting tours are going to
come at right but blogger bob has a
great sense of humor I saw guys a plate
of bacon Nora I got you oh it was not me
I'm still amazing people get in the TSA
line and they still don't know what
they're supposed to take out and what
they're supposed to push through and all
that cuz they're annoying you know they
slow down the process thank you Chris